I put together some really impressive
deals but this thing you've pulled off
it's amazing a big and tasty for just a
dollar how do you do it what's your
secret
you're a man of few words I like that
got a buck you're in luck because you
can get a delicious beefy big and tasty
or a McChicken sandwich for just a
dollar every day at McDonald's purple
very very powerful
what up peeps I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report it is March 2nd 2023 we're
live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
locals uh there is no post game show
today I have to warn you believe it or
not I'm gonna blow your minds right now
I'm actually not here
I'm on a plane to New York yes that's
right we're taping this yesterday if
you're watching this today because I am
on Greg Gutfeld with an exclamation
point tonight Thursday night I'm doing
the Gutfeld program so uh we pre-tape
this for you fine people and hopefully
I'll uh be making Greg uncomfortable I
have a way of bringing out the best in
Greg I think and I was the one on the
first night of the Gutfeld late night
program to say that Craig would be
number one in late night I think I said
it was going to take six months it only
took him three months but he is the king
of late night television which is pretty
spectacular and then I'll have a day on
Friday to be in New York doing my thing
and hopefully I won't get mugged
murdered or otherwise accosted uh anyway
we've got a reubenreport.locals.com
Community Q a for you but before we do I
wanted to do one story today because I
saw this clip of uh former VP Mike Pence
I believe this is on CNBC talking about
what governor DeSantis just accomplished
by going after Disney and it is a really
rather bizarre take but I think it shows
an interesting split and division Within
well certainly the Republican party but
I would say the the broad I always talk
about that broad conservative movement
and when and if you should use
government power to actually accomplish
things uh so here's former VP Mike Pence
so I fully support what Florida did
about protecting kids under the third
grade but I I have concerns about the
follow-on look Disney stepped into The
Fray they lost uh but then
they're taxing Authority I you know I
that was that was beyond the scope of
what I as a conservative limited
government Republican would be prepared
to do
interesting all right so before I add my
commentary as you know I had Governor
DeSantis on the show two or three days
ago and I asked him exactly why he did
what he did with Disney and what the
Fallout was going to be sign the bill to
finally uh eliminate their
self-governing status we've put the area
into State receivership I've appointed
people to to manage it we now have the
ability to apply Florida law to them
they used to be exempt from the building
code and all these other things we also
have the ability now so that they'll pay
their fair share of taxes which they
didn't have to do for the last six years
and of course they're going to honor all
the debts the Municipal debt that they
rung up 700 million dollars and so that
is um basically treating them like we
treat Sea World they're going to be just
another company so this is an
interesting moment for the again wide
conservative movement you want limited
government right I'm a limited
government guy I want the government off
my back but do you ever when you have
power power use the power of government
to accomplish anything now what's
particularly interesting about this case
and seems to be a lot of the confusion
that I think even perhaps Mike Pence is
confused about is that all that Governor
DeSantis is doing is stripping away the
special rights of Disney the corporation
right he's not using government power to
hurt a corporation he's just saying hey
you Corporation have to behave like
everybody else in other words Sea World
that was the example he used Sea World
is also in Orlando why doesn't SeaWorld
have their own special rights and
special building codes and why aren't
they allowed to get 700 million dollars
into debt and would that then be
something that you would want the
government to come in and be like hey
you got to pay your debts so from where
I sit DeSantis is obviously doing the
right thing let's let's put aside the
the whole fight about quote unquote
don't say gay you know it seems that
Pence is agreeing with him on that in
terms of getting the craziness out of
the schools but once the Disney decided
to get all in on this fight well
DeSantis decided to do something about
it and if you believe in the free market
which I think is a conservative
principle if you believe in Freedom I
think that's a conservative principle if
you believe in equality I think that's a
conservative principle and if you
believe In fairness I think that is a
conservative principle then of course
you would strip away special rights for
people or corporations we should have
equality not Equity so this is going to
be an interesting fight
for the Republicans and I and I think
it's a good one by the way while I
obviously disagree with Pence and you
know there are some people saying he's
going to run for president I don't sense
that he has any real support at this
point it's hard to figure out who that
is like the Trump people kind of don't
like him if you you know like so there's
just some some weirdness there but I
think it is a worthy fight of when you
use government power I just think he
seemingly is confused like this is the
type of stuff that people have had it
with the Republicans on it's like no
when you have power we don't want you to
abuse power we don't want giant
government overreach but we want you to
use it judiciously to expand Freedom
that's exactly what the scientists did
here uh I'd love to have Pence on to to
find out a little bit more about his
philosophy behind that that somehow your
only small government if you allow giant
corporations to do whatever they want
and not pay their debts and have
building codes that nobody else has what
is that that that's actually the
government granting them those things
the government granted them the ability
to have their autonomous zone now the
government's just taken it away I think
he may be a little confused about the
issues or something along those lines
let's get to the Community Q a vika says
do you have any clips from pre-red Bill
Dave monologues to show us a bit of your
Evolution my God people I hope we've
burned all of those and scrubbed them
from the internet I mean I'm sure
there's stuff out there right like
there's gotta be but don't come to me
asking for that drivel okay
you can probably find them at
youtube.com we didn't delete any of our
old stuff like it's there I always find
it funny these people come after me
they'll find like a clip from you know
2014 where I'm like you know I like
Bernie Sanders and they'll be like see
Reuben was a Bernie Sanders supporter
I'm like yeah I was I was sleeping now
I'm awake like you're not getting me you
think you're getting me because I admit
exactly what went on here just filling
it anyway I wouldn't waste your time
with that enjoy the new show we're
trying to bring out some better ideas
these days Curtis says okay Dave the
truth are you wearing shorts right now I
am wearing pants can I if I move a
little bit what's going to happen here
I'm wearing hats can I get the yep but
I'm not wearing shoes how about that
that's that's a little something for the
people and I got my ankle socks on not
wearing shorts right now I have a policy
this is my one policy as you know
because I'm also the uh in charge of the
production company here and my one
policy is we cannot wear shorts in
studio nobody wants to see just white
legs especially indoors nobody wants to
see them and that's that's the one
policy so that's what we do Jamie says
do you think the sand worm voting block
was responsible for Beetlejuice losing
the election or did she lose favor with
the civil servants Union that all
committed suicide this is a rather
clever commentary comparing Lori
Lightfoot to Beetlejuice I get all the
references there
that that scene when he first goes in uh
you know he's in purgatory or whatever
it is and the woman with that really
really where's the boys
boys it's just great just great Michael
Keaton is just a great actor does anyone
not like Michael Keaton Michael Keaton
right it's like you gotta like Michael
Keaton talway says have you Daphne or
any of the crew tried any of the recipes
that have been submitted for the
community cookbook so if you guys have
not seen this if you're not part of the
locals Community we are uh we are
compiling dozens and dozens I don't even
know how many we're going to take
ultimately of Community member recipes
across the board is it soup is it
chicken related is it a dessert is it a
salad whatever it might be are you bacon
something whatever
and we're going to do a Reuben report
locals Community cookbook that's
separate than the cookbook that David
and I have been working on for quite
some time but we're just kind of with
the kids it's just like it's tough right
now on that one but we are going to
actually print it and we're going to
send it to community members and it's
going to be it's going to be made by the
community uh I actually have not seen
any of the recipes yet we we posted this
what about two weeks ago Daphne has been
compiling them I know a whole bunch of
you guys have sent things in I guess
we'll kind of go go with them together
and then I thought I thought the next
version of this would it would be fun to
cook things together on certain nights
so we would like lay out a schedule so
people know what recipes uh they're
going to do so they know what
ingredients to get and that we would all
actually cook the same thing and we can
post our pictures of it and all that
good stuff so if you're watching on
YouTube Rumble and you want to join us
reubenport.locals.com in case you had
not heard movie junkie 86 says what do
you think about these videos showing
School teachers and students fighting
someone tweeted a video this morning of
a man shooting another man in the middle
of the day right on the street Candace
Owens talked about the 80 year old who
was killed by dogs recently and someone
posted a video of it what are your
thoughts about people filming these
events they may not be committing the
crime but some don't seem to be trying
to stop it or get help so first let me
address the the school one first there
you see these videos every day if you're
if you're on Twitter or I guess they're
on Tick Tock usually they seem to come
from Tick Tock onto Twitter if you see
these videos they're horrific putting
aside every circumstance that got
led up to the teacher and the kid coming
to blows these are awful and you see
giant melee's students attacking
students students attacking teachers
teachers attacking students it goes to
the to the cultural rot that obviously
we spend a lot of time talking about
here and your question really is related
to what about the people that are
filming these things like you you watch
them you see these things on the subway
where you know a man will be attacking a
woman
and people were just filming it or a
woman you actually see it more the other
way because women are more emboldened to
attack men uh at least in public places
so you'll see women attack men and
everyone just stands there filming it
right so that's just like a conditioning
of this thing that we're all just like
we're just in we're just in that thing
um but I don't you know it's it's like
sometimes you see horrible things and
you think people should get involved and
then in some of these cities where you
know the police aren't going to help or
they're afraid or they're they're simply
not going to show up whatever whatever
it is I could see why good people don't
get involved it's it's a real problem
you know there was a very famous uh case
I may be slightly butchering this but I
think this was in the 70s if I'm not
mistaken this was in Queens or Brooklyn
it was the Kitty Genovese the Genovese
family there used to be a Genovese
drugstore it was big in Long Island and
I think it was in Queens and Kitty
Genovese I think was it was her was uh
was murdered in the middle of the street
or attacked in the middle of the street
and basically no one did everything
anything about it and everyone that was
watching because was you know a little
New York City Queens type Street
everybody said oh someone else was going
to do we assumed someone else called the
cops and nobody did anything and it's
weird because now we're all videotaping
it and no one does anything I think
again I think it's it's we have a real
cultural rot with this thing that video
that you're referencing was in St Louis
by the way the guy just executing what
appeared to be a homeless guy middle of
the street 2 p.m St Louis broad daylight
wasn't on CNN wasn't on the New York
Times
is what it is uh Mickey says hey Dave
since Lori Lightfoot is looking for a
new job and you're looking for a new
intern what would it do would you hire
what would you hire Lori to do I guess
scare the children is that a part of any
of your jobs because I could take that
off your plate if we really just want to
scare the children at night you know
imagine imagine you're a little baby
like I got my kids down there imagine
like you're crying and then Lori
Lightfoot appears to soothe you you'd
freak out
I don't know what else you could like
talk about a no skilled person like
like what let what skill does this woman
have what job could she possibly get
after this I have no idea Michaela says
your interview with Peter Thiel just
showed how important new views ideas and
creativity is concerning creative
expression art does does play a great
role I'm sorry concerning creative
expression art does play a great role
only that it is in a similar bad State
as the rest of the societal land slash
mindscape my question does art painting
sculptures play a role in Dave's worth I
love this question I'm so glad you asked
first off if you if you haven't seen my
interview with Peter the full things on
locals already the part one and I think
maybe part two is up on YouTube and
Rumble right now
and I think Peter's just great like
we've actually become quite good friends
and he's just an interesting interesting
dude like I've had big big dinner
parties with him where we they try to he
always tries to set up one conversation
at the table so it could literally be 30
people and everyone gets a chance to
talk chime in debate but it's not just
broken down into 15 conversations of two
where you can't hear and whatever it's
like well let's all really talk about a
big idea which is something I've tried
to incorporate in some of our dinner
parties as well but on the art front you
know it's interesting there was a big
art fair uh about a week ago in Coconut
Grove here in Miami and I went and my
sister-in-law is a brilliant brilliant
artist uh her name's Kalyn Janet you can
go to Kalin
c-a-y-l-i-n Rose janet.com and you can
see many of the paintings that she that
we've commissioned for her she we have a
lot of wall space here and she's done
massive awesome art installations for us
hyperspace is one that I know a bunch of
you guys have purchased prints of but
she's done amazing wax things and she's
done clay things for us and really some
incredible incredible stuff
um and anyway so I went with her to the
art fair and it's kind of fun it's fun
and also like kind of crazy going to an
art fair with an artist because
obviously they're looking at oh I could
create this and look how much they're
charging for that but she's she's very
open and decent and wonderful and we saw
a few things that you know that I did
kind of like that were you know the one
thing that I really liked the whole art
fair was about nineteen thousand dollars
and I was like all right that's that
horse it's like a cool horse and there
was like a snake and it kind of but like
I'm not spending 19 Grand on this thing
um but art and music you know we're
constantly playing music in the house I
the first thing I do in the morning is I
put some music on I usually put on some
like morning jazz or something like that
I've mentioned I like the rippingtons in
the morning they're like a sort of
melodic I think they were big in the 90s
kind of kind of group
um but you know I'm always doing night
time I'm doing my Frankie Valli and my
Frank Sinatra and I like a lot of chill
channels and I've really been into Yacht
Rock lately uh but yeah heart is a
really important important piece you
know looking at something that that has
beauty that makes you think that that's
why it's so depressing when you talk
about the cultural rot that like it's so
rare now to find a movie that really
moves you or gives you a new idea or you
know when I can always talk about Star
Wars like how the last Star Wars movies
they get worse each time you watch them
where a good movie gets better watch the
movie contact one of my favorite movies
it gets better every time you watch it
you can think about it in a new way uh
try Cloud Atlas which I've been meaning
to watch again but I've watched like
five times and you get more out of it
each time V for Vendetta you get more
each time bad movies like there the
script is written in constructed in such
a way that
it will it will trip you up each time
and it get worse each time so we need
good art be it music or
paintings sculpture whatever it might be
matimbo says do you have any thoughts or
comments about the Newsmax vs Direct TV
kerfuffle is it a contract dispute or
does Newsmax really have a valid
grievance for censorship so I don't know
all of the nitty-gritty I know about the
case obviously a Newsmax uh is being
kicked off of DirecTV and it sounds like
they're arguing that this is a clear
case of cancel culture it sounds like
DirecTV is arguing that there's a little
more Nuance to it
um I think in essence this is why we
just need new pipes for everything you
know if Newsmax gets kicked off
altogether they will fully be welcome on
Rumble right and Rumble we've got a Roku
app you guys are watching this on locals
right now we're building out all of the
infrastructure to do all of those things
so we just have to think of new ways to
get things across so if you're if you're
a more traditional executive at a place
like Newsmax and I really like the
Newsmax guys I you know I love doing
John boxman John Bachman the show
particularly on Thursdays but I like
Spicer I like all those guys it's like
you may just have to think of a new way
like whether it's cancel culture and
it's unjust or whether there's a
contract dispute or whatever the
whatever the minutia is it may all be a
moot point you may just want to really
start thinking about how do you protect
your businesses it's exactly what we did
here right like I am not going to be
kicked off rumble or locals I'm not and
Rumble is not going to be kicked off the
internet because they run their own
infrastructure and now locals is run on
rumble's infrastructure so we are
rebuilding the internet a piece at a
time and if you take these issues
seriously maybe we're past the point
where just you know waving your
grievance flag and that's not fair and
DirecTV shouldn't do that maybe that's
just over and done with and you got to
go you got to go find the business
partners that want to be in business
with you uh snow baby says would you
ever consider doing a non-political
shows members only once a blue moon what
about a cooking show with David David we
are thinking about a bunch of things my
time right now is so crushed uh because
you know obviously we're busy in general
with the show and and traveling and
doing the things that I do for this
obviously what you know the guidance
that I'm giving the folks over at locals
and Rumble and things like that there
are two children downstairs and you got
to feed these things every day you guys
know about that I'm feeding these guys
like multiple times a day and pooping
and all that stuff
um but I would like to do more you know
we built a really nice cool outdoor
barbecue bar situation
and I would love to shoot a show there
maybe have a couple drinks with some
guests and kind of work it out we are
working on on an idea for a live studio
show uh but also I think you were really
talking about getting away from politics
a bit Yeah we actually have a list of
people that we want to talk to that are
that are a little bit more on the
cultural entertainment side and and just
kind of
keep it fresh I mean one of the reasons
I do the August Off the Grid thing is
because otherwise the politics
I love it obviously I love it obviously
I'm super excited about what's going on
here in Florida obviously I think that
might be exported in a major way in the
coming months across the country and who
knows what my involvement with in that
would be I have no idea but like also I
do care about some other things and uh
and it's important to to focus on those
two uh Richard says what are your
thoughts on the Scott Adams controversy
was he wrong so if you have not heard
about this there's a major controversy
involving Scott Adams first off I like
Scott Adams I consider him a friend he
is a good man and uh that let me just
put that there period Scott by the way
we got him involved in locals he loved
it so much immediately very early on he
was like hey I'd love to I'd love to
invest can I can I throw some money into
this thing because I really believe in
it and he's he put his money where his
mouth is and he's just a good man the
controversy basically is this there was
a video going viral
where we're produced by a leftist
organization with a series of black
people basically in essence saying they
don't like white people and here's why
and it was promoted by this Lefty
organization okay and Scott watched it
um and and then he also saw this there
was this other poll uh that basically uh
50 of black Americans think it's wrong
to be white I don't know how accurate
the poll is you know my feelings about
polls in general but he watched this
video and then that poll and then what
he commented on on his live stream he
does this live stream on locals all the
time well he does a live stream all over
the place but now he's being canceled
left and right so I think it'll probably
be exclusive on local soon enough in
essence what he said was my advice to
white people would be not to go to areas
where there are a bunch of people who
hate you going off the information he
had just heard he did not say anything
racist he did not say I don't like black
people he didn't say you shouldn't like
black people or anything like that he
was taking a certain set of information
that he had heard and then said what
what is the real what is the reality of
this if these people want special laws
for One race and another loss for
another race we used to call that racist
right
um you know imagine let's say uh 50 of
Germans said that uh you know you
shouldn't like Jews you think there
would be a problem there so so
again putting aside the percentages on
this and everything else all he said was
my advice to you would be well you
wouldn't want to move into a
neighborhood like that anyway a bunch of
newspapers canceled Dilbert he got a his
book with penguin which is my publisher
the publisher I've used in the past I
suspect I will not be using them again
uh he uh got his next book canceled by
them and a whole bunch of other stuff
but he wisely is on Rumble and locals
anyway I think he's a good dude he he's
he's inflammatory and he's intentionally
inflammatory and he likes poking the
bear
um that's part of what he does but he he
is not a racist silly nonsense
um Mike says hey Dave my girlfriend of
eight years just recently became my wife
congratulations and we're planning a
trip to Miami in April to you David the
Reuben Report Team or Clyde have any
recommendations for cool but reasonably
priced restaurants or hangout spots
where we can get decent food and drinks
in the South Beach area I want to make
sure we do this Miami trip right
I feel like you got better cool spots
than I got you got some cool spots dude
I don't you know I don't do South Beach
that much because it's like that's you
know it's it's the party atmosphere I'm
kind of Aging out man I like a nice cool
chill restaurant uh I love Coconut Grove
Coconut Grove just has great great
restaurants you can't go wrong anywhere
you gotta try mr01 pizza for sure
there's a couple locations in Miami uh
the Key Club in Coconut Grove is pretty
awesome uh if you go to Coral Gables
there is a restaurant called Lulu an
Italian restaurant it is phenomenal
we've done a bunch of my team member
birthday birthday birthdays there I wish
I could remember that waitress's name
she's so good and and the food is just
absolutely spectacular being told by
Phoenix that Lincoln Road in South Beach
is quite good you also might want to try
to get down to the keys if you want to
try something a little bit different a
little not just like hardcore Miami
Miami and what else do I like around
here walk around Winwood see the
Windwood what do they call the Windwood
walls I guess they call it all the they
have like funky graffiti over there and
I'll try to think of some other things
message message Us in the in the
Community again before you head out
we'll come up with a list for you uh
Karina says Dave have you noticed since
Governor DeSantis has become a very
public figure that every negative story
out of Florida is now national news I
used to see my home state Colorado a lot
on national news now I feel like it's
Florida yeah everything that happens
here and that's why I keep saying you
can tell who the threat to the system is
right now no one's really going after
Trump right now
if that's just the fact right like no
one is most people are are either
ignoring him or his his hardcore people
are backing him no matter what right but
the machine is kind of ignoring him
right now that's just how it is DeSantis
no matter what he does
is get national news right like look I
live in Florida we focus on Florida
because I think it's the blueprint and I
do want the show every day to give you a
positive Vision that positive Vision
happens to be emanating out of the
Sunshine State that's that's a pretty
beautiful thing uh he also because of
this this sort of
um
said but unsaid situation or I guess
it's all unsaid but it's implied that
he's probably going to run for president
I think that's creating a situation
where they want to go after him early
right and Trump only sees him as the
threat Trump doesn't see Nikki Haley as
the threat he doesn't see Mike Pompeo as
the threat or anything else so Trump is
going after him as I said the the Pence
thing that we started with here is
bizarre it's like man Pence that's such
an easy win for you such an easy win to
be like you know what what DeSantis did
for the kids with the bill was right and
what the scientists did to stop Disney
from getting special treatment was right
what a win but he wants to create a
wedge with DeSantis my guess is because
Pence is probably going to run it's not
going to go well for pets I don't even
know why he's even thinking about it
like he just doesn't have a base like
that
uh all right let's see what else Joe
says when did things get weird I figure
things started getting weird around 2013
or 14 when micro micro aggressions and
Twitter warnings were introduced on
college campuses maybe it was the
introduction of the smartphone what say
you Dave
I think there's a lot of ways to look at
the weirdness I think the probably real
blanket answer of when things really
went nutty yeah
was when this thing got in all of our
phone in our in our lower phones when it
got in all of our hands when did the
original iPhone come out maybe around
2005 or so is that 2007. so 2007. so
first you know we had phones before that
and you had you know slower text and
black and white phones and you could
play Snake and whatever then we got this
thing we had apps you had GPS we started
because of social media the way that
really exploded you know you found you
reconnected with people who you liked
for the moment you've reconnected with
them then you hated them then as I
always talk about the feed on Facebook
there's an explosion in the Middle East
there's a picture of a baby it's
Grandma's birthday there was a murder in
Indiana like it it all is just making us
wacky then somehow politics became our
national sport I think when you add the
fact that the algorithms were highly
manipulated to make us addicted you also
had this this endless scroll thing right
websites back in my day used to have an
end you'd go to cnn.com it would end you
just scroll to the end there was nothing
else to look at now they doom scroll you
forever I think all of these things have
kind of worked against us I don't think
there's exactly one moment you can point
to but however your point on 2013-14
microaggressions and all that kind of
stuff that was definitely connected to
my wake up around 2014 right that's when
I started as a lefty saying something's
not right here why are we shouting down
speakers what's going on at college
campuses all of those things and that I
do think you know because everyone used
to say the same thing to me when I was
doing it
at first and saying you know we're not
acting liberally and all those things
everybody I mean I mean from pundits to
family members everybody would say the
same Dave you're just wasting your time
you're talking about college kids the
second they get out of college the real
world's going to hit them they're going
to fold like a wet paper bag that'll be
it and I just did not feel that was the
case I I don't know what it is I just
saw something I think it has something
to do with look I was on The Young Turks
they were influential at the time
fortunately they're not so much anymore
but I saw the just like the hysteria and
anger and how they were disseminating it
to people and all of those things and I
just felt this thing was gonna burst
forth I don't think anyone could have
predicted this where we're at now but I
would also say that's why we have this
little uh this little window to fix it
and uh we're living in the window of the
window over here uh Gina The Nomad says
does Rumble headquarters offer tours
I'll be nearby in a couple of weeks on a
family vacation and would love to get a
tour they don't yet I don't know that
that's in the in the cards at the moment
you know right now we've we've got one
Studio there and then it's just it's
mostly people doing work so you know
it's offices and conference rooms the
Dave Rubin conference room on the
executive floor pretty cool
um but the studios themselves you know
it right now there's only one Studio
there so it's not necessarily something
it might be kind of cool to see just
where where people go to do these things
I there are plans to build a whole bunch
of bigger Studios really all over the
country probably again start with a
little more here in Florida first
there's a lot of plans I can't reveal
everything at the moment but you know
we've got the the local studios here in
Miami the uh the rumble Studios over
there in Longboat Key
um but if you show up there there are a
lot of security guards you know you can
tell them you don't know Dave Rubin but
don't do that you know just but go to
Longboat Key it's really lovely get a
nice group or sandwich Elizabeth says
what's your favorite childhood memory
that's tough
what's my favorite childhood memory uh
you know I remember my grandma my
grandma Mimi taking me and my brother
this has got to be 1985. to the original
Transformers movie and she said I
remember her saying something like kids
I'm gonna fall asleep during this thing
she fell asleep by the time the opening
credits began my brother and I our our
minds were blown I mean they kill
Optimus Prime right at the beginning of
that move have you seen that one even
the original cartoon Transformers oh
they kill Optimus Prime they kill
Starscream Galvatron disintegrates him I
mean it's disturbing
there's some great music in there you've
got the touch I hope some of these
references are making sense to you
people
um but I remember it was just like a
great day it was just a great and then
we had milkshakes so milkshakes in the
original Transformers movie much better
than Michael Bay Transformers movie and
not having a milkshake I think we can
all agree on that
people
watch Gutfeld tonight I'll be on and
then I'll be in New York tomorrow but we
are pre-taping a show for that too uh
James Lindsey will be my guest as well
as
TBD
2B wait that's 2B delayed TBA to be
announced
to be determined it's TBD and TBA
part two of my interview with Peter
Thiel is up across platforms full things
on locals we leave you with the cold
clothes
adios amigos
I like it but I don't like it at the
same time this is fantastic oh thank you
for giving me this this well welcome
back great welcome back